[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
restait 35 minutes devant devant de
personnes debout sur un poteau tu as
bien deux cherchent une top 3
[Applaudissements]
j'ai caché les soldes les choses
métissage et les ados désolé on peut ton
parti monter ton parti monter arrêterait
pas personnes arrêtées 9 janvier vers
nantes ou spa ou alors vous allez tous
vous donne et vos appréciations va
démarrer par géraldine manier d'abord
votre appréciation il finira offrir un
par la dow jones jean miché le maire
vous êtes un cancre adorable vous êtes
un peu branleur un train lander elle
autant dire une chanson de marqueurs
célibataires dont un peu dandy élégant
un peu de mauvaise foi pour tous c'est
peu moi je pense que vous êtes
totalement indispensable autour de la
table de tpm p moi j'ai de la tendresse
pour nous parce que vous avez des
problèmes de diction on parle on parle
bien sûr des deux des trois premiers
mois parle pas là du début d'année
c'est la tendresse pour vous parce que
vous avez donc beaucoup de problèmes de
diction et vous redonner confiance à des
dizaines de milliers de berg en france
et en cela je vraiment je vous félicite
après moi j'ai un petit peu peur face
aux jazz chaussée limitant je vous le
dis alors quoi on ne se pose pas marrant
ça pourquoi mais je voulais pas être
marin d'accord et ensuite jean michel je
vais vous dire que vous aimez être
sifflé vous aimez qu'on vous charrie
vous aimé qu'on vous conspuez et c'est
pour ça que moi je vous ai mis un 6 1 6
avec une mise en garde aux comportements
parce qu'en fait j'ai peur pour vous
j'ai peur de votre masochisme faites
attention à vous jean michel l hôtel
nous amènera conseil de classe gens me
rassure ah non mais les races race à la
halle et époux thierry moreau jean
michel c'est mon meilleur camarade dans
la bande à noah s'amuse-t-il d'ailleurs
quoi mon meilleur camarade dans la bande
et culte colin et bond c'est un mot qui
lui va bien
il fait mon éducation sexuelle tous les
soirs avec lui j'apprends des mots des
expressions des positions il travaille
pas beaucoup je suis obligé de lui
donner un petit peu le sommaire de
l'émission pendant les pendant le
générique parce qu'il n'a jamais bossé
il dit je suis mal habillé je lui en
veux pas trop mais il a le lui la
chemise qui vaille comme comme
aujourd'hui au niveau de jeu du bide
mais voilà il me fait rire c'est un bon
camarade donc je lui donne ainsi ces
demies l'encouragement aux six et demi
c'est pas mal si scénarii pour votre
pote et il ya des pagnes notre prince
albert attention isabelle morini-bosc
bon camarade temps partiel gisement
obscurci par ses pulsions sexuelles du
moment de même temps qu'on est
absolument pas certain qu'il aime les
couleurs aussi souvent qu'il le dit à
tout jugement
quand ils oublient devant un kikoo à la
place du cerveau c'est un élément qui
est indispensable à la bonne marche de
l'équipe tout de même devrait penser à
se muscler le vide avant de faire des
réflexions sur le physique des autres
mais comme je les aime beaucoup qu'il
était sympa au ski qui devrait dire plus
souvent tout de même le doute m'habite
et ben je lui mets quand même si ses
nuits à pas mal chez ses ennemis pour
l'heure elle a bossé la beauce et elle a
écrit et tous ses biens et laura jean
michel tu sais à quel point je t'aime tu
es un des membres fondateurs de cette
émission est essentielle à l'émission
vraiment tous les soirs quand tu n'es
pas là tu nous manques et on a découvert
des choses à montrer
on a découvert depuis la rentrée qu'il
était drôle qui ne parlait pas que de
son zizi que tu n'étais pas qu'une sex
machine c'est un petit côté sniper alors
on a eu peur un peu con couilles mais
snipers en revanche ce que je te
recoudre ce que je te reproche c'est
d'avoir délaissé au profit de mathieu
delormeau
donc je le dis devant toute la france je
suis en pleine crise de jalousie sa
table que point car tu me manques une
t'occuper de ta blondasse alors je ne te
mettrais que c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'il est vraiment cul et
chemise avec mathieu maton non mais
c'est vrai que vous avez bien lu je suis
avec matthieu delormeau et je me demande
comment vous allez faire l'année
prochaine
mathieu sévin mangeant mais ça fait une
déclaration d'amour ça qu'on s'entend
très très très bien j'apprécie plein de
chose de toi t'as bisexualité notamment
que tu que cette année qui commence un
peu à paraître qui se reconnaîtrait très
agréable visiblement il n'est pas encore
prévu il était de dos il a rien vu alors
[Applaudissements]
mille excuses ne pas là on ne parlera
que l'émission est pas du tout dedans
alors que tous là mais les curieux
cc c'est comme ça qu'on définit
l'intelligence et c'est vrai qu'on en a
déjà parlé il est curieux le week end
je voudrais pas plus il échoua koala aux
néophytes
il est curieux week end écoulé
franchement je sais me plaît bien
évidemment dit miser faute et att de
mauvaise foi tu tu bosses pas tu es
menteur d'ailleurs même pauvre type aux
commandes et amis pour dire à quel point
de dkm doué mais voilà mais honnêtement
je pense que cette année pour être sûr
2007 à meilleure année vraiment pouvoir
eu beaucoup de touche pas à mon poste
est extrêmement drôle tu est cultivé tu
as vita beaucoup de répartie et je pense
franchement peut-être que je me trompe
j'aime tout le monde dans l'équipe mais
je crois qu'actuellement nous le plus
indiqué parlait même pas tout le monde
alors mes joueurs est actuellement très
vraiment le plus indispensable donc
franchement des plus indispensables moi
je dirais le plus mais qu il veut
maintenant que j'irai le plus mais voilà
jean lucien mathieu qui d'ici là je
dirais le place donc voilà c'est à 9
très méritée
dans le sens par hasard comme par hasard
le 9 à l'envers est assez bizarre
voilà merci monsieur
non mais c'est sans faire exprès au plus
tard mais voilà il me 9 à son pote qui
rouleront le groupe parce que c'est mon
pad vraiment vraiment je pense
qu'actuellement c'est leur usage et
semsales c'est bayeux je dirai ce que je
pense d'eux me jean-michel également
benjamin bailly c'est vrai c'est un
élément indispensable dans l'équipe
moi je trouve extrêmement drôle il fait
dehiba très vite c'est vrai qu'ils
n'empruntent pas une ça on est tous
d'accord là dessus mais c'est pas très
grave je pense que son apport dans
l'émission c'est sa bonne humeur ses
blagues très situé en dessous de la
ceinture mais personnellement c'est pas
moi qui vais jeter la première pierre
non ce sens ni la dernière ni la
dernière voilà donc il faudra faire des
efforts d'articulation il savait en
statue de sa cellule c est en revanche
quand tu parles de télé bon je préfère
quand tu parles de faim parce que
vivement tu connais beaucoup mieux car
il était journaliste au figaro et ben ça
ne se voit pas ce journaliste très bon
journaliste est vrai pour toutes ces
raisons je te mets à trets un très beau
ça celui ci est donc attention on va
voir l'appréciation de gilbert barre
jean michel mais quel gâchis mais quel
gâchis
vous avez du talent mais vous avez
complètement épuisé ce talent à force de
vivre sur vos acquis ou de fréquenter
mathieu je ne sais pas vous vous
repreniez vous avez perdu votre punch
avait perdu votre élocution vous est
même devenu mauvais camarade et gris
parfois contre vous même et contre
l'avis mais pour vous mettre votre note
je veux faire abstraction de l'affectif
c'est vraiment le chroniqueur hydra
l'homme que je note et jean-michel vos
prestations sont inégales vous êtes
brillant le lundi vous êtes calamiteux
du mardi au vendredi
mais par grandeur d'âme je ne prends que
cette journée du lundi une journée
unique je vous mets donc à remarquable 1
et
il est très bon alors j'ai laissé la
dernière appréciation et la dernière
note avant laurent baffie agent lui
parce que je pense que c'est celui qui
le connaît le mieux puisque c'est demain
où il est cavalière et c'est vrai que
jean michel maire il est limite plus
présents dans la pub pour ses voiles je
voulais dire c'est lui qui avait le
dernier mot au fait sur janvier
c'est ça c'est particulier moi je trouve
qu'il a une très bonne diction pour
quelqu'un qui vient directement de boîte
de nuit le plateau alors j'ai justement
les off donc je peux témoigner
il bosse pas mais très souvent il
connaît pas le nom des invités jeudi a
pas vu les programmes ils demandent des
sèche à thierry moreau est riche il
baille à l'écran aurait des limites
souvent tes vrais points c'est une
phrase une pub c'est comme ça que c'est
donc pour toutes ces raisons il est
indispensable aux 4e et 8e lors la ville
adopte la note est en plus bel olo est
ce que vous connaissez ce monsieur bah
oui même si je regarde l'émission la
nuit en replay non il est très
sympathique il a pas de la bonne humeur
il est j'y vois là moi je les aime bien
je les veux embrasser du plastique et si
votre courageux quand même quand vous
avez combien j'aimais 5 s'il avait
embrassé les deux nichons jours à 1010
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner ma note également avant
d'avoir la note des téléspectateurs je
pense que c'est la meilleure saison de
jean-michel depuis le début de touche
pas à mon poste c'est sa meilleure
saison parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il
est en roue libre
oui il se dit voilà ça y est il est là
il a fait un petit peu il ya un petit
peu de pression l'an dernier c'est vrai
c'est vrai et cette année je le sens
voilà sans pression il a tout lâché
enfin ne lâchez pas tout quand même mais
et je le trouve voilà excellents cette
année qu'il adore un trou c'est un des
meilleurs d'ailleurs celui ça de ce qui
fait le plus d'émissions et jean-michel
je vous mets huit ennemis non mêmes même
si me base pas même s'il ne passe pas on
les aime comme ça allez on va voir la
note des prix tous les chroniqueurs
julin les twittos 7,3 sur dix c'est
énorme à 6,7
donc vous avez les encouragements mais
je crois que vous êtes le premier de la
classe pour l'instant jean-michel on va
voir que fit le classement des élèves
s'il vous plaît je crois que ces
deuxièmes des urnes la classe sociale
deux derniers premiers opus rapidement
merci je crois que vous êtes et bien sûr
valérie quénéhervé 2e de la classe 9
l'on me siffle alors est ce que le
reggae
c'est à avoir une bonne note franchement
surtout de vous ben voila et je suis
vraiment touché parce que je sens qu
rien de la sincérité chez tous mes
camarades même chez gilles et bien oui
on veut pas du tout voilà moi je suis
content c'est une formidable aventure je
vis ici depuis sept ans maintenant
donc j'ai vécu les choses plus de choses
en sept ans que dans le tout le reste de
ma vie professionnelle
et voilà et ça continue et vous me
surprenez toujours mes camarades et vous
et franchement je m'en souviendrai bas
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours qui sont
proches
[Applaudissements]